[Music]
they're in the shadow realm how do you
know
the atmosphere there has a darkness like
no other this is if color feels to tread
it's unmistakable well then if it's
color we need
let's bring the rainbow
bring the rainbow is her catchphrase or
something she's only been a thor for a
minute i mean saving lives she's quite
good at but the rest of it she needs
work how many catchphrases have there
been a lot
yup
jumped the gun hang on he moves through
shadows and he's going to the shadow
realm it seems like that's where he's
going to be the most powerful you're
right we can't just go marching in there
it could be a trap are you thinking what
i think you're thinking i'm thinking it
what are we thinking thinking we're
taking it too i'm living
[Music]
there's the maniac who seeks to end us
all
i'm putting together the greatest team
ever are you packed
yes
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
you said this would be a relaxing
holiday
i said it was going to be like a
relaxing holiday
human handshake
see how's guardian shake
into the snake
that you cannot trust
really dragging us out and finish the
classic asgardian high one
it theaters july 8 tickets on sale now
[Music]
you